crossed the border lips a little a man
with the power of 10 a man who casts a
shadow appeared and as far as Gotham
City the wind carries his name bane bane
and now hi-ho Batman must face his
greatest challenge you tricked me
wouldn't have shown you the Crystal
Skull if I had heard your laugh ah hey
say your cunning nose no bounce and we
turn the page Riddler
there he is he was under a mask it's the
Riddler the dogmatic duo back to badger
me yet again I was going to pay for this
skull oh how do you know a likely story
a yow Robin is attacked by a polar bear
the Riddler knocks on top of Robin a
bear going for a twink
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm just trying to keep it relevant
thanks.thanks stop bad nappies and
wearing those short pants you Gary's the
guy I'll give you that Robin I wasn't
going to give the asking price of $5,000
I left mr. Carlton with something of
more value one of my personal
handcrafted artisanal rid of that means
he took a [ __ ] in the form of a question
mark
[Laughter]
partly market value Riddler oh he had
the skull for underpriced anyway it's
much more valuable to certain parties
now stop keeping teams up so late good
night Batman with his Riddler Cain he
releases someone I guess is gas and
knocks everybody out yeah but then they
cut to it they cut to a new day as
opposed to cutting Robin fills us in man
spoilers yeah but you don't think the
Riddler would take this moment to be
like I'm looking under the mask he's
trying to get away dude yeah but he has
a minute [ __ ] advantage he could
literally shoot them both in the head
what is wrong with you I'm just saying
this [ __ ] starts to not make sense at
age 47 thank you yes gas him okay
on to the next page a new day
my head is still pounding from Riddler's
gasps see they fill it in so I knew that
part but why wouldn't the Riddler be
like oh my god I'll at least put his
mouth on his sleepy dick I'm the Riddler
this shit's artisanal he's the Riddler
not the diddler okay that's why drink
more water Chum we need clear minds to
parse this latest riddle Friday stealing
skulls is no small thing now to watch a
man steal a ring stuff and nonsense
trying to lead us astray can't complain
man that's not a stereotype that's good
I would offend me if I was Irish well
then never nonsense chief O'Hara the
Riddler has a mental block that compels
him to admit his fiendish goals and
apparently a mental block about just
taking him up [ __ ] mask oh you stop
with the mass it's really not important
just apply a little logic is all I'm
saying
but his puzzle obsessed mine contorts
those truths into riddles in an attempt
to stay secret
Friday so whatever he's planning happens
tonight to steal a ring maybe he's going
to hit fortunes jurors maybe it's not
that kind of ring Boy Wonder
well Batgirl sounds kind of evil let's
get something a little more heroic than
that yes we'll take a take two what is
she in traffic
well that window the whimpers that
windows open behind her so we're here in
those three maybe you need
she got clipped mind if I join in no no
we want to take two
give her the lead in a Boy Wonder maybe
she's no baby I've lost control of the
sex you have it's not the first time
here we go
Ralph's gonna give you your lead-in and
then your gonna dive in okay with a with
a different Ralph apparently had an
issue said your back girls sounded evil
I thought it was good
but she should be more upbeat let's just
get one more for the studio oh my god
here we go and action maybe he's going
to hit poor tins jewelers maybe it's not
that kind of bring Boy Wonder
oh I like that feel Batgirl ladies and
gentlemen give it up for Batgirl
[Music]
you
[Music]